[Applause]
everybody have their own theme music
hello everyone hello everyone all right
if you don't follow me on Twitter you
should know as somebody it's not going
to be a quiet room welcome to unintended
consequences how to reduce exclusionary
practices in our organizations and
communities I am Kim Creighton yes you
can use the hashtag cause a scene you
can find me at Kim Creighton 1 I have a
website hashtag called the scene as well
as Kim Creighton dot-com after this
slide I usually would put my credentials
in there but you know I don't cause it's
such a scene I don't care if you don't
trust what I have to say I know what I'm
talking about so there it is
first and also there it is so let's
define some terms I am an educator by
trade my only Intertek four years ago
and I like to start everybody on the
same page so that when I get into my
talk people aren't saying and I don't
know what that means so we just start
off everybody the same place privilege
is about access when I talk about
privilege I don't just talk about race
and gender and all these things I talk
about access that means that there's a
group of people who have more access to
resources connections than other groups
that's what Act privileges is that
simple it's about access and so I use
this picture because everybody people
have seen these little monkeys in Japan
they think oh that's so cute but right
there is an example of access because
there's a family a female family group
that is only they're the only ones who
get in the water the other monkeys on
the outside they got a feel for them
if they freeze it downs they freeze it
up so it's only a family of monkeys that
can get in so this family has access to
this pool of this hot water where others
don't
underrepresented is about numbers so
that's all it is in tech white women are
underrepresented marginalize is about
treatment in tech many white women are
not marginalized so I'd like to make
that distinction because when you when
people say they want diversity adding a
white woman to your team or to your
panel is not diversity diversity is
about variety I know I'm from the States
and that we have Crayola Crayons when
you get that big box that was the only
child so I got a sixty-four box of
crayons I had a lot of variety that's
what variety is about diversity is about
to me inclusion is the Holy Grail
it is about experience it is about
everyone having the experience they
expect when they come in contact with
your business your community or your
event inclusion is not about equity
because if you white man and I black
woman from the south of the United
States start the race at the same time
you're still gonna be ahead of me I need
you to stop sit down for a second and
let me catch up and pass you the very
clusion is not about quotas
that's under-representation inclusion is
about people's experiences with your
companies your communities and your
events all right so are we going to talk
about some businesses here and these are
some of the things that get that I find
that get individuals in in trouble or
get them in places they don't want to be
with these unintended consequences is
because many people think they have a
business when in fact they have a
product or service a product of product
or service is not a business a business
requires processes policies and
procedures
that allow you to grow the scale to
recover but just for the fact that you
have created a product or service you do
not necessarily have a business that's
why VC can come in and take over your
company because they bring in those
skills to help you grow and and
everything else and I and I blame the
lean canvas model for this because that
is about iterating a product or service
and not about a business also you cannot
manage what you do not measure you can't
you can guess but you never know where
you are exactly if you cannot MIT you
cannot manage it if you cannot measure
it so I'm not a person who reads off of
the things honestly these things are
appear so I don't remember what I am cuz
I ant live a lot so all too often
organizations fail and when I say
organizations I mean businesses and
communities I'm gonna make that one
thing so when I'm talking about
organizations that's what I'm talking
about because our become toxic because
the leaders don't understand that growth
requires processes that enable
connectedness innovation and competitive
advantage what happens is you have a
group of okay we're just gonna talk
about white man because that's what
we're full of have a group of white man
to go to university they come up with
this project and they oh this is great
let's do this ad to make money and they
step over here with the same mentality
they had when they're in their friends
they have not thought about business
being different so they behave the same
way they stay up the same amount of
hours that used to that's why you have
these ping pong tables that women and
people in marginalized groups we could
care less about all that I'm going home
I don't even know how to play ping pong
I can't even keep it on the table we
don't I'm not interested in drinking
beer with you on the job I want to do my
job and I want to go home successful
organizations are built on foundations
that enable their leaders to turn
information into knowledge in order to
scale evolve and recover that's what a
business is if you can't scale it if you
can't recover or if you can't
what you created for yourself is a job
it is not a business so you see people
who work in restaurants and they can't
ever leave they have to be there all day
that's a job they've created a job for
themselves you want to work be able to
work on your business and not work in
your business and so um and we as we all
know being technologists Google has
everything but just because you can find
information on Google does not mean you
it's knowledge for you you have to do
something to internalize that
information before it becomes knowledge
so it's a lived experience and that's
one point that they're missing the
ability for organization leads to
successfully create and manage
operations relies heavily on how well
there are a development necessary
processes so here we talked about you
have to have the information that turns
in the knowledge that will allow you to
scale evolve and to recover and then you
need to be able to have the Ackermann
the ability to put those processes in
place to allow you to scale evolve
recover and I'm gonna be honest with you
many of you don't have these many of you
are developers many you don't care to
learn anything else but as I say it many
of my talks if you don't have these
human centric skills you will be out of
a job soon and you will be one or the
other I on the other hand who has a
different set of technical skills you
have technology skills I have a
different set of technical skills I hate
on people call my skills soft cuz
they're not soft cause as many of you
don't have them I because I am a person
who can deal with human beings I always
have a job you need to start thinking
about that when leaders take the time to
understand and operationalize this is
the key word operationalize their
organization's functions they avoid
common barriers to success while being
able to recover more quickly from
unexpected events unexpected events are
going to happen
as the first speaker talked about errors
we know that's just not in our code when
you're building a business you're
testing stuff you're trying stuff out
you think you have it and then you wake
up and there's that there's an your
site's down or something your accountant
ran off with your money whatever it is
there will be unexpected events having
these things in place allow you to
prepare at least for some of that me
businesses have no plans in place
they're just going on and whatever
happens happens and then they're just
like I don't know I don't know why I
can't betray analytical has our data I
don't know why we didn't go back after
four years and somebody said hey there's
somebody check it said they destroyed
that I don't know all these things
because there aren't processes in place
building a successful organization with
fewer unintended consequences requires
more than a great product to serve as
again a product or service is not a
business it requires leaders being able
to give all stakeholders all
stakeholders the experiences they want
and the ability to manage the process
this is where inclusion comes in is
about experiences and I'm going to tell
you what stakeholders I'm talking about
in just a moment but I also to give my
I'd like to talk to leaders because I
have nothing against people who are not
in leadership but you have absolutely no
power no agency no resources and you
cannot move these things forward and
what you do is become burnt out you
become frustrated because they're
telling you at the top of these things
are important to you but they're not
giving you any resources of backing so
that you can do anything with it so
you're banging your head against the
ceiling and they're telling you you're
doing such a great job and then you feel
guilty for not you know I'm tired but
this is such a you know want to be more
inclusive and I don't know this has to
come from leadership so when I talk
about all stakeholders I believe
building businesses for social change we
are at a time where everybody has access
to information we are at a time where
pretty a lot of people are very
polarized and I can speak from the
United States I don't want to make any
assumptions about Germany but I know our
government is not run by politicians it
is run by business owners it is run by
very wealthy business owners who can pay
lobbyists to give money to politicians
and politicians in turn make decisions
based on the money they're received so
when we talk about when I say all
stakeholders in a traditional business
it's about just the shareholder and this
is what gets me because people get all
upset about jobs leaving and I'm gonna
give you some business and education if
you don't know this in the United States
again don't know about German it is
illegal for a Board of Directors or a
CEO their first priority has to be
shakin stake shareholder value so if
they do something or make a decision
that would not bring the shareholders as
much money as possible they can be sued
by said shareholders so I found it quite
interesting that during the previous
election all of these people were upset
about where coal jobs are gone and
nobody ain't bringing them back the
carrier
people they thought they were gonna
those jobs weren't gonna go to Mexico I
don't care who Trump is or who everybody
else is the shareholders of that company
owned net company and the CEO and the
board of directors have to do whatever
they can to to make sure that
shareholders are not only not losing
money but are increasing their profits
that is what shareholders about
stakeholders are looking at other people
in the company and this is where you get
the inclusiveness because if you only
think about shareholder value how
inclusive can you actually be that's why
there is no money in it because you
can't justify
everybody's to me there is there's data
about ROI return on investment when you
have a very inclusive teams and I'm sure
you if you work on inclusive teams you
know that you have better
you can create better you can create
something together that you couldn't
create by yourself but if your main
thing is about shareholder value if
giving something to into inclusion and
diversity and no shareholders don't see
an immediate return on the value you're
not gonna get that money so we're
talking about stakeholder values this is
what this is the business model I
believe in and it's talking about
considering those who work for you those
who partner with you those who buy from
you and those who invest in you and I
have it in there order for a reason your
employees the people who work for you
are your most important asset periods
they determine how any customer
experience is going to be so you need to
make sure that you have thought about
how to improve the experiences of those
internal stakeholders and then you're
gonna go outside a bubble and those are
your partner's maybe your supply chain
whose if you're making t-shirts the
company you choose to make your t-shirts
these are the things you need to think
about because you might pick a company
that has policies that you don't believe
in but you've partnered with them
because you haven't thought about these
things also who buys from you
everybody's not going to buy from you
there are some clients you made you will
not want but you can't know that I'll be
able to articulate that well if you have
not made these determinations if you
have not thought about these things and
also those who aren't invest in you
everybody's just running out here for
this VC money
MailChimp was um was named X company 100
the fund number one country company for
2017 and they have not taken a bit of
venture capitalists money so when we
talk about investing you we need to
think about especially like we're
talking about communities your local
JavaScript who's investing their time in
you who's sponsoring you and those are
the four stakeholders you need to think
about going going from a product or
service focus
to business model focus takes time and
you've got to stop expecting simple
solutions to complex problems this is
what gets us in trouble
it takes intention which means I want to
do something but wanting to do it is not
enough you have to have a strategy in
place to make it happen all are
necessary in order to innovate
differentiate and compete in the
information age you do not have a
business if you cannot not in the
information age if you cannot innovate
and differentiate yourself there are two
ways you can get competitive advantage
through differentiation and price and I
don't think anybody really wants off but
to battle anybody on price but when you
differentiate differentiate your
services and products you can you can
really if this really something look at
love your time no one really needs a
little bit oh I'm bad but I see tons of
them all you need is a sack from the
grocery store but people have different
ideas or what they value also building
stakeholder rather than shareholder
focus organizations is a proactive
approach to addressing inclusion to
diversity and safe occurs in taste we
have to stop doing this throwing
spaghetti up on the wall and seeing with
what little sticks we have to have a
plan he has to be strategic because when
we don't do that
underrepresented in marginalized
individuals or harm to by our actions
this is the very reason I have issues
with Stack Overflow to this day and if
somebody in here has a problem with that
I don't care I have a serious problem
that for the last three years their
survey indicates that 92 percent of
their survey participants were white
males between the ages of 18 and 34
white males between the 18 years at 18
and 34 you are my target audience
because you are the bottleneck you are
in the way it's nothing wrong with you I
have nothing against you but you are in
the way and what I don't like about the
Stack Overflow issue is the fact that
businesses are looking at that as if
that is a representation of
global community it is not it is a
representation of those individuals who
feel safe enough to engage and gamify
stay on stackoverflow
[Applause]
I'm currently hearing that people are
going on interviews and people are
asking all I need to see is your github
and your Stack Overflow score what what
does that have to do with me doing my
day to day job but because women people
of color people with disabilities are
not actively engaging on Stack Overflow
they don't have the scores which means
these decisions by business leaders are
impacting us financially and you really
don't have a right to mess up my money
so stop making these stupid decisions so
we're gonna come take you to a process
from shipping shifting from a product or
service focused to a business model
focus so step one I have my clients
imagine imagine what the ideal
stakeholder experience would look like I
really don't have people my clients even
talk about their product or service
until week until several sessions later
because that doesn't matter because if
you do this product right you can pivot
you can change you can do everything you
should not be married to a product or
service that's also what gets us in
trouble because we get to that we can't
change it and even though our customers
all my stakeholders are saying this is
not working for me
stackoverflow um you still have to do it
you're holding on to this and those who
follow me know that I'm just into
stackoverflow right now so I have a
problem because they are the is it the
hub in the wheel yeah the hub of every
developer community in the world you
cannot tell me that the we're especially
we're talking about a I machine learning
and deep learning that that day that
that code on that website is not biased
so you have people who don't feel safe
enough to engage on that site so they're
just copying and pasting code at some
point there's going to be a tipping
point when we have a problem
so so this process is not outlining um
it's not outlining session so you're not
saying step one step two you really want
to get into the field how you want your
customers to feel when they come in
contact with your organization it's not
about product or service at this point
what do you want them to feel when they
come and contact with you when they
reach out to you and say I need help
because that's why they're coming to you
I need help
well how do you want them to feel
through the whole process and this takes
time some clients I had recently they
thought it was gonna be because they're
in El Salvador they thought it was going
to take a few hours no it took them a
week to do that to get my assignment
back to me because you really have to
think deeply about this so it's time for
you to tap into the emotions because
again we go back to Louis Vuitton only
big reason people are buying that is
because there's an emotional attachment
to that
that's what quality high priced goods
are they elicit an emotion in us and you
want to use adjectives descriptive words
so this is an example I'm gonna give you
it so you want to apply measurements to
your indicates so you want to create
indicators so this is me um oops yeah
okay so define so Mike um you want to
put a company company name has a
commitment to so Kim Creighton LLC has a
commitment to facilitating honest
conversations and strategic action for
positive change and technology in the
technology sector anybody in here who
follows me knows that's what I do
so now you want to define your core
values
my company is to promote positive
organizational and community change and
fun and engaging ways that's why do the
music that's what I have the conferences
that's why I have the shirts this stuff
is hard enough I need people to feel
safe and comfortable and welcome to have
these challenging complex conversations
um so you'd want to know what that looks
like what that experience looks like so
then you want to define your indicators
so for me it's to get more clients so
that means meeting to me I would know
that I have more clients because I'm
meeting or exceeding my monthly
financial goals I'm getting attention
because I have a significant growth in
brand awareness I'm getting more Twitter
followers I'm getting more Instagram
followers I'm getting people to come to
my conferences I'm getting people who
are saying hey do you want to be on my
podcast and then I want data I want to
track tracking client outcome so when
I'm working with my personal clients I
want to make sure I provide them with a
a testimonial a simple thing that anyway
that's all I have to do is fill in the
blanks or at my enema my conference is a
survey or something I want to get that
data then you want to apply it you want
to apply measurements again you cannot
manage what you cannot measure so to get
clients since X number of dollars it per
month by December 18 31st get attention
be a guest on X number of podcasts or be
again be right in X number of
publications by this time and I will
identify that and get data X number of
testimonials referrals and sponsorships
these are things that I have identified
so that I can measure myself against it
and so then I asked myself what must we
must reach this benchmark to know that
we can claim success so we can't say oh
I got halfway there because if you're
not measuring so you can say oh I got
halfway there but these are the reasons
why I only got halfway there so there
may be a success you only maybe got
halfway there because you had the pivot
and had a more successful opportunity
but you won't know that if you have not
sat down and wrote written these things
out this step is where a deep where you
develop effective metrics for measuring
your core values so my core values again
are to promote positive organization and
community change in fun and engaging
ways and this is how you turn cuz people
like how do you get these adjectives
edge and that this is why Kota conducts
don't work all the time because be nice
what does that mean everybody has a
different idea what be nice is you need
to be able to figure out words that are
measurable um I also don't like
harassment cuz if you've not defined
harassment in the beginning some people
have a different idea what harassment is
we see that within me two movements and
then you want to test you want to test
the indicators with your stakeholders
and you want to collect data from there
data are the facts but again that's not
enough you want their feedback their
feelings and their reactions so it's two
ways of collecting data you want I mean
collecting information so you want to
get that that hard data that
quantitative data but you also want to
get that qualitative data because
without both you do not have a complete
picture and then you want to evaluate
your measurements to determine if your
benchmarks were met and this is where
people mess up you want to know why if
you were if you did meet what did you do
and write that stuff down if you did not
talk about it and write that stuff down
use knowledge to get news knowledge
gained from evaluation of testing to
refine the process and you're gonna
iterate I tell people as you're
iterating your product or service you
need to be iterating your culture your
core values you need to be testing
getting customer feedback getting
stakeholder feedback figuring out does
this work is this working for you if not
okay we need to change there how do we
need to change that okay and you need to
be doing it just like a sprint and then
you need to standardize it you create
form once you have something that's
concrete a little I mean more concrete
cuz it's never gonna be concrete you
need to create formal processes based on
the knowledge gained from the
evaluations you need to document
explicit language an explicit means
those things you can write your
documentation a documentation is the
best way of one of the first ways that
you can be more inclusive in your
communities you need to be writing
documentation in particular if you have
customers that use that to create or use
that to answer questions your
documentation is not a one-stop thing it
is a continuous cycle and you need to
share tacit knowledge tacit knowledge
than what you turn information into
personal knowledge or and so if I am
doing something and I have a task and
I've done it a few times now I have my
own way of doing that you need to not
only you capture that but that needs to
be shared throughout the organization
because in an information economy it is
that tacit knowledge that will allow you
to differentiate that would allow you to
differentiate and be competitive not
this book knowledge not these binders
that's not the information you need
that's going to make you competitive so
important considerations core values
should be should inform all
organizational decisions and we're going
to show you what I mean in a minute
remember that this is an ongoing process
the decisions that are the result of
this process should be seen and not seen
as immutable or rigid organizational
leaders should plan to review whether
stakeholder factors have changed at
least at a minimum two times a year
because you need to be shifting when
leaders create organizations around will
defined and tested core values that
consider the stake all the needs of all
stakeholders and have processes in place
to monitor progress again it's all
stakeholders and measurements they are
less likely to discover at some point in
the future that they've been nurturing a
toxic environment this is my first
example of what I talk about my core
values were to change this this
community in a positive way and the fun
way right so the first example of this
fits in to my core values I have cause
of C hashtag Colosseum merchandise it's
just saying is that I say that people
like that I talk about I'm gonna be
honest with you I don't ever remember
what I said in my talks so people come
back and say oh you sound like that's
good I'm gonna write that down so I have
several items on this website because
again I have a problem with people not
wanting to pay for this I just like you
go to work every day you expect to check
the things I do I expect to get paid for
the second example yeah exactly
the second example is the conference so
the conference is is it's all about I'm
so against
so
and I'm a special needs and certified so
I'm used to working with students and
having dim it to demonstrate how to do
something so I'm really sick of people
talking like oh we just can't find
underrepresented and marginalize people
to speak at our comes we just can't find
it you don't have an excuse anymore cuz
I'm showing you how to do it so again my
conference is Monday night I'm sorry I
used the English thing so I was informed
in something I think and I'm talking
7:30 in the morning Oh hex know it's
7:30 p.m. till 11 p.m. it's not in the
morning the next example of me using my
core values to make decisions is my
podcast that just launched on Wednesday
this past Wednesday and it's the raw
deal Holyfield I'm gonna tell you we are
talking about everything because we need
to have these conversations so we can
move through them it is not until we
have these challenging conversations and
white men I'm gonna tell you if you're
feeling uncomfortable you're only
feeling this much and calm discomfort I
walk around in this every single day if
I can deal you care
[Applause]
and the fourth example is the leadership
training the coaching that I'm doing I'm
doing some consulting while I'm here and
this is I'm doing so this is also
showing you or giving you a
demonstration of how I've used my core
values to dictate how I get to my core
my stakeholders and my customers so
thank you
[Applause]